どうもイエーイ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ボディペイント
というわけで皆さんボディペイントした
ことありますでしょうか僕も動画で何回か
そのボディペイントやったことがありまし
て例えばその全身に世界一黒い塗料を塗っ
たりだとか僕の家に鉄道があるんですけど
も
像になりきるとかいろんなボディペイント
がしてみたんですけどもボディペイントの
可能性って無限
今日もイケメンです
ボディペイントの可能性で無限だと思っ
てるんですよ4億円の家に来る前のお家
カーテンの柄がすごかったんですけども
それにもうやめてしまったんですけど昔の
メンバーが擬態させると思う気づかなくて
すごいと思ったので今回ちょっとそれを
もっとフルに利用して4名のイケメンに
かくれんぼボディビンとして隠れて
もらおうと思っておりますちょっと皆さん
ね今日してもらうことになってしまいまし
たはい
どう思いました
マジかと俺はまだ何も聞いてないですこの
家に擬態してもらってボディペイントで
隠れてもらって僕が鬼で探しに行きます皆
さんを
見つけたやつから殺していって
かくれんぼって言うけど皆さん隠れません
もういるだけだもんねその場にいればいい
だけなのでそれでちょっと僕が鬼でも今日
してみたいと思いますボディペイントさん
に人によって56時間かかると思います
[拍手]
のでここであのちょっとチンしただけさせ
ていただきます
早速ちょっと塗っていきましょう僕全く見
ないようにするので
[音楽]
間違えたごめんごめんごめん
素敵で準備ができたっぽいので早速
探しに行きたいと思いますこの4億円の
うちの中に4人人間が隠れているという
ことでちょっとそれを見つけに行きたいと
思います早速行きましょう
人がさこの4kの家に擬態してると結構
すごいと思うんだよねまあ普通だったら1
階から行くとこなんですけども逆に今日4
階から行ってみて探すのちょっと4回行き
ます
[音楽]
隠れる所っていうかいっぱいありますから
ね広石ここ今回はもう隠れてないからね
言うてよ家の話なんですよさすがに
余裕で見つけれると思うんですよね
20分ですか
20分からちょっとわかりました頑張って
見つけたいと思いますよろしくお願いし
ます
行きます
4回失礼します
どこだとりあえずこの部屋ではないと思う
のよこの部屋から出るなって売れたから
この部屋ではないことはわかるんですけど
もどこなんだろう
[音楽]
じゃあここら辺もなんか
いない気がするけどな性質いきます
失礼します
さあ寝室着きましたいつも俺が寝てる
ベッドですね
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってよ
ちょっと待ってあれいや気のせいだったら
わかんないけど俺の恐竜あんな顔だったっ
け2匹は置いてあるのよなんかあんな感じ
だけ恐竜
3匹になった
けど
見つけました今
[拍手]
角度見たらマジで恐竜だったマジですか
わかんないんですけどなんかそのなんて
言うんだろう全く
わかんなくて
すごい
悔しい
はい一人目見つけました
影の入り方シャドウの入り方とかでマジで
わかんなかったパッと見すごいなこの
レベルのやつが出てくるのか次行き
ましょうか4人でしょ各階に1人みたいな
可能性ありそうだな次は3回行きますさあ
3回いきましょうか
[音楽]
HIKAKINさんあんなしわくちゃだっ
けなんか
怖いな
誰だ
ぞ
見つけました
鼻に目があるのね
[音楽]
なかなか顔にヒカキンさんのその部分ある
人いないぞ
すごいマジで
怖い恐怖感じるちょっとこれね分かりまし
た顔がちょっとピクピクってなってから
入った瞬間えってなってます
[音楽]
見つけましたこの感じは各階に一人なのか
わかんないけどちょっと見てみましょうか
ソードの限らないからね
3階
[音楽]
管理人質
いやー大丈夫だと思います多分大丈夫さあ
残り10分ですちょっと半分なので急ぎ
ましょう半分でさ2人探せてるからペース
的にはいいんじゃないか
まずどこにいるかがわかんないのが本当に
こういう画角にもいるかもしれないって
ことでしょ
こういうとこも大丈夫だよね洗剤とかに
なってないよね2階の部屋入ります
失礼します
[音楽]
どこだ
どこかにいるはずなんだ
[音楽]
キッチンは多分いなそうですね多分大丈夫
ちょっと待って
いやしっかり差し込んどるな
誰これ
[音楽]
すごいよ
足立見つけました
時間的に後ろの太陽が差し込んでて
薪の隙間から光がちょっと入ってるのが
デカかったですね
すごいよ結構マジで足までちゃんと椅子の
色になってるのね
[音楽]
見つけましたあと一人隠れてるんで
ちょっと急ぎましょうよっしゃあと1人
どこだ1回行きます外もありますか
ちょっと残り時間考えると結構苦しいぞ
この
編集部屋入ります
[音楽]
失礼します
急げ
[音楽]
これ人間か
いやこの部屋じゃないこの部屋じゃないわ
どこだちょっと占い行きましょうか
[音楽]
どこにいるんだ
いやここもいないんじゃないかな
いなそういなそう
サウナとか
急げ思ってる時間がないぞ始め
こことかも結構擬態しやすい気がするんだ
けどな
いやいないないないいないいない
残り2分です
かそもそも室内にいる可能性ってこと
でしょ
最後だけちょっとレベル高いんじゃないか
やばいぞ
いなくね
ステルス部隊だね
見つけました
マジで気づかんかったマジで気づかんかっ
たよ
葉っぱの再現度やばい
ちゃんと人だ
背中だけ何も本当だ
5時間かかりましたお
疲れ様です
全然気づかなかった
[音楽]
あーでもやっぱり家主ということで強い
ですね家の周りの微妙な変化なんとか無事
全員見つけることができました
[音楽]
[拍手]
はい日本のマーベルです
お疲れ様でしたお疲れ様でしたどうでした
僕だけ唯一外で
[音楽]
簡単に地獄でしたね
暑いしね
登ってくるんですよ動かせないから
口で
動かして
たかったですね1回スルーしていきそうに
なったから
すごかったですかレッド
[音楽]
ブルーグリーン
途中から参入した味方に寝返ったブラック
芸術の域なのよ
ねもうずっと他のコーラに合わせてこう
やってやった後こういう線があるから後ろ
の線にも合わせないとで距離見ながらね
はい動くさ
れるの
きついですよね
ミソキンの顔が動いてる
完璧だったかもしれないけどまた動画
ちょっとミスってね動いちゃって顔だけっ
ていうのもねむずいよいよサーブはマジ
これで高かったマジですかベッド2匹いる
のか上手いこと使われててマジで最初
わかんなかったですはいというわけで
ちょっと4件のうちでかくれんぼしてみた
んですけども
[音楽]
いややや簡単でした
ちょっとまたねこういう方法のかくれんぼ
もあるよっていうの今日やってみたので
ちょっとまた機会があったら新たな
かくれんぼを見つけてちょっとまたお家で
やってみたいと思いますバイバイ